في محاوله لاكتساب الرزقي وخلق مجال لعمل
المراه الافغانيه وفي بيئه منعزله من
الرجال تفتح سيده ندى داودي فندق من
السيدات للسيدات في مدينه كابول البيئه
النسويه بشكل كامل كما تقول العامله فيه
هذا الفندق
في هذه الظروف الصعبه في هذا المكان الامن
والمريح بنسبه للسيدات
على الحكم في كابول تقل صوت حركه المراه
الافغانيه وفعاليتها في كل من القطاعين
الخاص والحكومي ولازمت معظمهن للمنازل
تامل فرشته ان يحققه هذا الفندق الطفره
جيده في تحريك المراه الافغانيه وتحريضها
على المشاركه لاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه
بشكل مباشر
مشاكل في الطريق وحين نخرج من منازلنا
بانشاء مثل هذه الفنادق حيث تكون المراه
مسؤوله عن كل الاعمال فيها لكنها من
ارتفاع اسعار الوجبات فيه
اكلت هنا برجرا افغانيا طبعا كان لذيذه
والمكان خاص بالنساء كما تشاهد ولا يسمح
للرجال بالدخول
ان المراه الافغانيه كانت تلعب دورا بارزا
في القطاع الخاص في حين كانت سيدات
افغانيات يملكنا مؤسسات وشركات وحتى مدارس
وجامعات اهليه مخاوف تنتابو صاحبه الفندق
الذي فتحته براس مال 25,000
من اخفاقه وعدم الاستمرار في تقديم خدماته
وذلك لان اجره المكان باهظه وعدد الزبائن
ضئيل عبد الاله نادر العربيه كابول